every modern computer when you get right
down to the bare metal is doing
basically the same sort of thing
I've said before that computers are just
overgrown calculators but how do you go
from a simple calculator to playing
video games or sending stuff over the
internet or even decompressing and
displaying the millions of pixels in
this video
in short what's your computer actually
doing behind me is a scaled up version
of a computer but we're gonna go much
much simpler if you take apart your
phone or PC somewhere in the heart of it
will be a central processing unit or CPU
connected to all the other devices that
make it work now to show a really basic
example we're not gonna use all those
devices the first one we are going to
use is the clock with every tick of the
clock our CPU goes through a step in
what's called the fetch execute cycle or
fetch decode execute this clock is
slightly magic in that it takes every
time I click my fingers in the CPU I'm
gonna have three registers these are
bits of fast storage where the CPU holds
values that it's working on right now
these are a register that keeps track of
our instruction cycle another that loads
are instructions from memory and an
accumulator the final thing we need now
simplified computer is somewhere to keep
the instructions and any values that we
end up calculating that is RAM random
access memory and we call it random
access because it doesn't matter when or
in what order the information is read or
written so that is our computer let's
run a simple program all its gonna do is
count up the processor has three steps
fetch decode execute it will just repeat
those on a loop that's the one thing
that's actually built into it so we need
some instructions actually in memory so
let's load our program into RAM that Ram
is also used to store our answers our
outputs in the real world these would
all be stored in binary
but let's not overcomplicate things
right now let's keep them human readable
an instruction has two parts the first
part is the instruction itself and the
second part is usually a memory address
on each clock tick the CPU will do one
of three things it will fetch an
instruction from a memory address it
will decode that instruction and it will
execute that instruction round and round
in a loop so it's going to count up
we're going to begin
with a number and add one to it over and
over again fetch one clock tick the
program counter is set to zero so the
CPU fetches the instruction at address
zero in the memory and puts it into the
instruction register decode the CPU
decodes the instruction the first part
of the instruction and the second part
is a location in our case the
instruction is load and the address is
six so we will be loading the value in
address six into the accumulator execute
the CPU execute this instruction it
takes the value at address six unloads
it into the accumulator in this case the
value is 1
fetch the program counter is incremented
the CPU fetches the next instruction in
the next bit of the memory decode the
CPU decodes the instruction
this time it's add and the address is
seven so we'll be adding what's it
address 7 into what is already in the
accumulator execute the CPU executes the
instruction we add the value to address
7 and in this case it's the value 1 1
plus 1 is 2 fetch from the next memory
location number 2 decode an instruction
to store the value in the accumulator
into RAM at address 6 execute now notice
that we are over writing what's already
there so address 6 now has 2 in it
instead of 1 fetch a new instruction
jump with a jump the next address we
fetch from is the 1 in this instruction
decode so we're going to jump to address
number 1 execute the program counter is
now back at 1 the ability to jump to
loop and to build instructions
recursively is one of the foundations of
computer science so we're back up that
fetch from location 1 decode it's the
add instruction again execute our
accumulator still contains the values
from before so 2 plus 1 is 3 fetch
decode store again execute storing it
into location number 6 fetch decode
execute when we jump again
fetch decode execute fetch decode
execute we're in a loop and we're
counting upwards by one on every sixth
clock cycle our program with these
simple instructions doesn't have a halt
command or any way to interrupt it so it
will just keep incrementing that value
by one until the number becomes so large
it can no longer be held by the memory
address how it breaks then well that's a
whole other video my fingers are tired
this is a very fiddly way to program a
computer in theory it can be done but at
this level these instructions are just
encoded in raw binary data which is
basically unreadable for humans so we
can convert that base to binary to base
16 hexadecimal at that level we call it
machine code the next step up from that
is a symbolic language called assembly
which is a bit more readable but it's
still close to working at that bare
metal the original Prince of Persia game
was completely programmed in assembly
that is almost unbelievable to me
painstakingly figuring out each pixel
animation and encoding it into something
that the computer almost understands
directly programming like that is
complex and hard and prone to the sort
of human error that introduces massive
security problems it is difficult to
code and difficult to debug
so rather than dealing with the
messiness or well the pristine logic of
machine code higher-level languages were
developed as an intermediary step those
languages handle all of that memory
reading and writing for us so all we
need to focus on is what we actually
want the computer to do so here's my
code just the same instructions 3 is a
little bit differently phrased for
humans to be able to read I specify a
variable X I then write a function that
loops forever and each passing through
that loop we increment X by 1 once I've
written that code I then pass it to a
compiler which turns it into that
original machine code for me so when I
run the program it's loaded into the
computer's memory and executes it if I
want to run it on a completely different
type of computer a Mac instead of a PC I
can compile it for that CPU instead but
this still doesn't answer the question
of how the computer is doing something
as complex as decompressing and
displaying this video
the answer to that is speed at the speed
I was clicking at the end that we were
executing one instruction every couple
of seconds on one thread one bit of the
system a modern CPU executes billions of
instructions per second gigahertz on
multiple threads but at the heart of
your PC or your phone there is still
just a ticking clock and a fetch execute
cycle I've used a password manager for
years and if you are techie enough to
reach the end of this video you should
too I'm not just saying that because
this video is sponsored by dashlane a
password manager and if you go to
displaying calm slash Tom Scott you can
get a free 30-day trial of their premium
version why should you use - lame well
first reusing passwords is a terrible
idea if you like me a few years back
then you are reusing very similar
passwords that have a few letters
changed or how the site's name stuck
somewhere in them it's not great
one date of each one of those sites and
it would be time to start worrying these
days - Lane sits in my browser and when
I want to log in somewhere i unlock -
Lane with a single password that I have
to remember and it auto fills it for me
- Lane also stores an auto fills credit
cards and address information across
your devices and it's got a VPN to
encrypt your traffic on public Wi-Fi
networks if you want to if you are the
kind of person who can remember 20
character unique symbol filled passwords
for dozens of different sites
congratulations but if you're not
superhuman then your choices basically
use insecure passwords or use a password
manager now you could use post-it notes
on your monitor as a password manager or
you could use - Lane which generates
stores and auto fills long secure
different passwords for every site I
don't have to try and type in a 20
character password filled with symbols
on a phone anymore
I put up - Lane instead everything just
works synchronized on all my devices
across Windows Mac iPhone Android all
automatically it plugs into Chrome
Firefox edge Safari Opera even Internet
Explorer and despite the fact that it's
all synchronized in the cloud
- playing themselves don't know what
those passwords are and based on the
security architecture can never find
them out I'll explain that next time so
- Lane comm slash Tom Scott for a 30-day
free trial of dash
Premium which includes unlimited
password storage and sync and if you
like it you can use the code Tom Scott
for 10% off